décor noir et les coronavirus est une
menace réelle pour les populations
indigènes du monde entier et en
particulier pour les tribus isolées qui
sont les plus vulnérables de la planète
et qui reste très peu aux maladies
extérieures au sol un là où leurs terres
sont protégés ces tribus sont l'un des
peuples le plus en sécurité de la
planète à l'heure actuelle mais là où
leurs terres sont envahis et où il ya
des bouchons et des mineurs illégaux
mais aussi d'autres envahisseurs
illégaux et compris démissionnaire dans
ce cas les tribus sont particulièrement
à risque et le coronavirus pourrait
anéantir toute leur population tic et il
ya de nombreux territoires indigènes au
brésil où les invasions illégales ont
explosé depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir du
président ball soda rose il a encouragé
les invasions des terres indigènes et il
veut qu'elle soit utilisée pour l'agro
business afin d'être volé il encourage
également l'exploitation minière avec il
a donc encouragé les envahisseurs nous
l'avons vu dans tout le pays y compris
par exemple sur les terres du peuple
yanomami
parmi ces indigènes certains ont des
contacts avec la société mais d'autres
non ces derniers sont particulièrement
vulnérables
les yanomami ont signalé qu'il pourrait
y avoir jusqu'à 20000 envahisseurs
illégaux sur le territoire en ce moment
même
de même le peuple kaua'i va sans contact
avec la société dans l'ouest du brésil a
déclaré que beaucoup d'envahisseurs
essayer de rentrer dans leur territoire
les awa du nord-est du brésil et de
l'amazone ils ont eux aussi repérer des
envahisseurs dans cette région et ses
envahisseurs s'ils sont porteurs du
chronobus
cela pourrait être fatal pour les tribus
isolées bien sûr le corona virus est un
problème pour nous tous mais les peuples
indigènes y compris les tribus isolées
sont dans une catégorie différente dans
de nombreux cas ils sont
géographiquement très éloignés des
hôpitaux graphique les dalles et
humanité
lorsque nous parlons d'un des jeunes qui
ont des contacts avec la société
le problème pour eux et que leur mode de
vie communautaire pourrait encourager la
propagation du virus
bien qu'il prenne des précautions pour
s'isoler même des autres familles au
sein de leur communauté et qu'ils
prennent des précautions pour se mettre
en quarantaine dans la forêt mais il ya
toujours un risque que le virus puisse
les attentes et dur en ce qui concerne
les populations indigènes qui ont des
contacts avec la société
dans de nombreux cas y compris au brésil
il n'existe pas de système adéquat pour
s'occuper d'elle au brésil les
populations indigènes de tout le pays
réclame une amélioration du système de
santé fait un collègue aux années
brumath le président ball sonar août
avec la guerre qu'il a mené contre les
indigènes et son racisme à leur égard a
également réduit de manière drastique
les systèmes de santé dont ils
disposaient cela signifie qu'il se
trouve dans une situation très difficile
à l'heure actuelle il faut actuellement
pression et proteste avec beaucoup
d'énergie pour que le gouvernement
garantisse une réponse adéquate gros
navires magie pour les populations
indigènes a response
je pense que cela a ouvert les yeux du
monde entier et que les gens ont
maintenant réaliser s'il ne l'avait pas
déjà fait
le danger des nouvelles maladies pour
les tribus isolées c'est un danger
constant
non seulement avec le coronavirus mais
avec n'importe quelle autre maladie même
un simple rhume ou une grippe pourrait
les réduire à néant
nous encourageons donc nos partisans du
monde entier à s'impliquer dans la
campagne pour faire pression sur les
gouvernements afin de s'assurer que les
terres des fugues isolées soient
protégés ou qu'elle puisse survivre
s'épanouir et vivre de la manière
qu'elle choisisse sans coronavirus une
toute autre menace extérieure année à
dallas